jetzt sind auch die forschungsteams am
cern angefixt auch dort soll in
experimenten jetzt die super spannende
theorie vom ungarischen
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern auf die probe gestellt
werden
dieser hatte nämlich vor kurzem eine
neue fünfte naturgewalt aufgespürt eine
grundkraft die suche nach dem bislang
unbekannten teilchen mit der bezeichnung
x17 läuft weltweit nicht nur mit
hochdruck sondern geht jetzt auch in
eine neue runde können wir also schon
zeitnah mit einer echten sensation
rechnen tricks um science-fiction gibt's
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktivierte
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen
gerade haben wir erst darüber berichtet
dass ein ungarisches forschungsteam eine
fünfte grundkraft entdeckt hat und jetzt
gehen schon die ganz großen
forschungseinrichtungen mit auf die
suche das mysteriöse x17 teilchen müsste
33 mal so schwer sein wie ein elektron
und dabei eine energie von etwa 17
millionen elektronenvolt aufweisen
deshalb auch die bezeichnung x17 zwei
voneinander unabhängige experimente
eines ungarischen forschungsteams um den
physiker atilla krasznahorkai hatten
hinweise auf dieses äußerst mysteriöse
zeichen gegeben dass auch nichts
geringeres als eine fünfte naturgewalt
grundkraft schließen lassen soll gibt es
also neben der gravitation der
elektromagnetischen kraft und den beiden
nuklearen wechselwirkungen tatsächlich
noch eine bislang unentdeckte fünfte
grundkraft klar ist bislang nur dass das
eine echte sensation und ein wendepunkt
für die teilchenphysik wäre solch eine
entdeckung hätte das potenzial unser
verständnis des universums und der dort
herrschenden kräfte um 180 grad zu
drehen auch der dunkle materie könnte
man so endlich auf die schliche kommen
so die leise hoffnung doch bislang steht
der endgültige beweis noch aus und das
bereitet forschungsteams weltweit
schlaflose nächte jetzt haben sich auch
physikerinnen und physiker des
europäischen kernforschungszentrums cern
eingeschaltet laut einer aktuellen
pressemitteilung hatte das team der nsx
die von kollaboration am cern schon vor
einem jahr interesse an diesem
mysteriösen teilchen doch bei den
entsprechenden experimenten vor ort
konnten bislang keine hinweise dazu
aufgespürt werden der nsx zuvor sprecher
sergej
lenco bezeichnet die ergebnisse aus
ungarn deswegen als faszinierend
unterstreicht aber auch dass weitere
forschung dahingehend dringend notwendig
sei und zwar nicht nur in der theorie
sondern auch in experimenten was
allerdings keineswegs bedeutet dass das
cern die existenz des x17 teilchens
prinzipiell ausschließen doch der rcb
den sektor am cern muss für solch eine
intensive suche wohl noch ein wenig
aufgemotzt werden damit man sich dessen
ergebnisse wirklich sicher sein kann
dazu der physiker jesse tayler vom
renommierten massachusetts institute of
technology mit 2007 experiment should be
able to make definitiv measurement
zukunft für interpretation of the tongue
gnss rising trommeln jufa mental force
in vier jahren also sollte dieses
experiment am cern in der lage sein die
existenz einer neuen fundamentalen kraft
entweder zu widerlegen oder aber zu
bestätigen bis dahin könnten aber auch
mit hilfe anderer experimente wie
beispielsweise nsx iv weiter nach
hinweisen gesucht werden dabei sollen
isotope mit einem strahl aus vielen
milliarden elektronen beschossen werden
möglicherweise führen diese ja sogar zu
einer früheren entdeckung der bislang
noch hypothetische teilchen erste
hinweise auf x17 wollen der ungarische
flüssiger attila krasznahorkai und sein
team bereits bei experimenten im jahr
2016 entdeckt haben damals hatten die
fachleute den zerfall des beryllium
isotops im visier
dabei waren photonen entstanden die sich
in sekundenbruchteilen in ein elektron
und das entsprechende gegenstück das
positron umwandeln also materie und
antimaterie vereinfacht gesagt
beobachteten die fachleute nach eigenen
angaben einen äußerst seriösen trennungs
winkel dieser elektron positron paar war
etwa 140 grad bei dem mehr teilchen
entstanden als vorhergesagt waren also
deutlich mehr und das widerspricht
bisherigen theorien komplett für ihr
aktuelles experiment produzierten die
forschenden energetisch angeregte helium
kern auch diese senden photonen aus die
sich innerhalb sehr kurzer zeit in ein
elektron und ein positron also das
positiv geladene gegenstück umwandeln
auch hier trennten sich nach angaben der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
die elektronen und positronen paare
eine mysteriöse winkel von annähernd 100
15 grad deutlich öfter was so mit hilfe
von bisherigen modellen nicht erklärt
werden kann noch immer ist fraglich ob
es sich hierbei um einen messfehler
handelt oder aber um eine echte
sensation die überprüfungen der
ungarischen ergebnisse durch andere
fachleute ist jedenfalls noch nicht
erfolgt und das so genannte peer review
verfahren steht somit noch aus das ist
eine qualitätssichernde maßnahme bei der
unabhängige forscherinnen und forscher
studien nach objektiven kriterien
bewerten möglicherweise wissen wir also
bereits nach einer offiziellen
begutachtung genaueres dazu nsx zuvor
sprecher thomas cook mit youtube
experimenten effekt eher nuclear physics
effect of something completely new new
artikel die beobachtung in ungarn
könnten demnach nicht nur auf ein völlig
neues zeichen zurückzuführen sein
sondern auch auf einen experimentellen
oder kern physikalischen effekt doch
ganz abgesehen von x17 davon hält die
natur mit großer wahrscheinlichkeit noch
die ein oder andere überraschung in form
unbekannter teilchen bereit die wir
bislang noch nicht entdeckt haben und so
ist es nicht auszuschließen dass der
große durchbruch sogar schon morgen
passiert superschwerer elemente die jagd
nach neuer materie anklicken anschauen
und doktor watson abonnieren und da ist
ein supercooler kanal ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran